We've been chatting with the one and only, Ted Danson,
who's back in the new season of NBC's "Mr. Mayor."
All right, let's get back to it.
Is it possible to get Ted's take,
like you could, in a sentence, tell us your take on blank?
Yes.
Perfect, okay.
(audience laughs)
Here we go, everybody. It's Ted's take!
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Okay, your take on love.
Wow, well, if you're blessed to have love...
To be able to love someone and be loved in return
is really, to me, the reason why we're human beings.
It is the, it's heaven on earth.
I love that. Work!
I don't have any wisdom.
The reason why I'm still working at 74
is 'cause I love to go to work.
I love to drive through studio gates.
I love to turn right on James Stewart Avenue
and cross over Gregory Peck Street,
and show up at a studio and be surrounded by crew members
who you grow to adore over the years.
Yeah, I love going to work.
And I don't know if it defines me,
but it sure enriches my life.
Okay.
(audience applauds)
Amazing, and you are up there with those great gentlemen
that you just said, Peck and Stewart and Danson.
Family.
Family, wow.
Mary and I both, what brings us literally the most joy
is when we sit down to a table of 12 people now with kids,
grandkids, wives, spouses, boyfriends, 12 people,
and we sit down and we're surrounded by family,
brings us so much joy.
I don't know what to say. It's such a blessing.
I don't have anything wise to say except thank you.
No, the 12 people,
that painted the perfect storytelling picture.
I love it.
The one rule you live by.
Be kind, yeah.
Be kind to people.
Life can be scary and hard and tough
and all of that, so be kind.
Yes, that is perfect, perfect wisdom
from you.
(audience applauds)
Do you think that if they came to you
with like a "Cheers" reboot that you would ever do it?
I'm positive we would not.
(audience laughs)
First off, I think our creators,
Jimmy Burrows, Les and Glen Charles, wouldn't want it.
They'd like to rest on their laurels, I'm sure.
But here's what it would look like.
It'd be a bunch of old people sitting around the bar going,
"What? What'd you say?
(audience laughs)
A horse walks into a what?"
(laughs) You know?
I think there would be an appetite for it,
but I'm just gonna watch the reruns for now.
And thank you for just being kind enough
to put yourself out there on all these incredible shows,
so that we can watch you, Ted Danson.
(audience applauds)
You can watch "Mr. Mayor" Tuesdays
at 8:30 Eastern on NBC.
Ted, I love you so much.
Thank you for being you.
Yeah,
I love you, too, Drew.
Ah!
I love you, too.
I'm so glad you have this show.
(upbeat pop music)